no it was embarrassing it was I I mean
if you can imagine at the time I sort of
I'd say to my friends I'm doing this
film about a load of girls playing
soccer and it's called Bend It Like
Beckham and they were oh really
that sounds really uncool Keira hello
since both of your parents were actors
I'm wondering if you ever questioned
whether there was a genetic component
that guided you in your future career ah
I think it's it's a lack of imagination
actually yeah maybe you know I mean I
think it's very difficult to kind of
have been brought up with actors and
writers and directors and that kind of
creativity and not be fascinated by it
you know it always feels like you can
change the world or it did when I was
small and I was I was watching my
parents so I think it was always
something that I want to be a part
remember the first time you kind of
sense this is what you wanted to do
I never remember wanting to do anything
else I wish that I did because I think
it would be so much more interesting if
I could say yes I wanted to be a fireman
or I wanted to be something but it was
always I mean apparently and obviously I
don't remember but apparently I asked
for an agent at the age of three did
they get you one no they they didn't and
I was really angry and they finally got
me one when I was six which is so it
took a lot of a lot of work to get that
agent I'm pretty sure that I didn't know
what one was I think they were just
always calling the house and I didn't
understand why I didn't have one so they
obliged me when I was six and the first
role your agent got you was was in
something called a royal celebration
when I was six and I think my whole
character involved running in and going
mummy daddy and running out again I
thought I was brilliant even when you
were this young and there were actors
and playwrights hanging around with
their particular actors that you
remembered that you wanted to be like it
was always Emma Thompson um I was
completely obsessed by by much ado about
nothing
um and I watched it so many times that
the video broke and I think my mum
bought it for me about three times I
used to know the whole thing off by
heart I don't anymore might be quite
useful if I did now but I don't
and then sense and sensibility was
complete and in fact all her work I was
completely obsessed by how did your part
in the Phantom Menace come about which
many people may not even know you were
you know I was 12 like they do and they
still do with a lot of big-budget films
they don't give you a script and they
don't tell you what the character is so
you go to an audition and then one day
they phoned and this at all you've got a
part but they didn't say what the part
was so I turned up going oh I've got a
part in Star Wars and actually it turned
out that I'd got hired because I looked
the same as Natalie Portman and I was
her stand-in and occasionally they'd use
me in the back of shots and I think I
mean I haven't seen the film since I was
about 13 so I'm not actually quite sure
what the part was um well the rumors are
that Natalie Portman ended up dubbing
your part yeah she could have done I
mean I don't remember saying anything
I'm pretty sure I was just in the back
of the shots but but I could have done
and she could have done I have no idea
there were several other roles in some
British miniseries like Oliver Twist
before your global breakout in Bend It
Like Beckham wonder if you could take us
through that adventure for you did you
know going in that this was going to be
something special
no it was embarrassing it was I mean if
you can imagine at the time I sort of
I'd say to my friends I'm doing this
film about a load of girls playing
soccer and it's called Bend It Like
Beckham and they were oh really
that sounds really uncool ya know so we
had absolutely no idea and the reason
I've got it was actually because I'd
done a film the year before called the
hole which was about a bunch of
teenagers getting stuck down a hole and
dying it's really good you should check
it out
led to a soccer court that led to my
soccer career yeah and I think I was the
only girl that went in that could
actually I mean I was obsessed by soccer
at that point so I could really talk
about it very passionately and very
passionately about about women's soccer
because I'd actually given speeches
about it at school and so I think that's
kind of what got me the part but no we
had no idea and I mean still it's kind
of astonishing you know the the success
that it's adding the fact that it's
lasted because I don't want to say when
I made it I made it when I was 16 and
now I'm 29 you do the math I can't
tell us what it was like though when you
started the sense that something was
different in the reaction of this film
and what it was going to do to you as an
actress actually I mean at that point
I'm not sure that I ever did it all sort
of goes into a blur from 16 so 17 when
Bend It Like Beckham actually came out
and I then got Pirates of the Caribbean
and I got Love Actually and I got a TV
version of Doctor Zhivago and it just
kind of all snowballed from from that
point so from that point on for the next
sort of five or six years I was just on
a film set and I think I mean the reason
I got pirates or they wanted to see me
for pirates was because of Bend It Like
Beckham so I suppose it did sort of
launch all the Pirates was kind of like
entering another galaxy here you were in
the realm of Jerry Bruckheimer
big-budget film making yeah tell us what
it's like for a Brit to suddenly enter
this kind of Hollywood Colossus it was
mad I mean I'm particularly I don't know
if it's a brittle just as a 17 year old
you know and I remember going to
Hollywood for the first time or actually
I'd only packed a small bag when I went
over to make it cuz I was convinced they
were going to fire me and and I actually
went for that audition and I was angry
at my agent for sending me to it cuz I
was doing I was doing exams at school I
thought there's no way I'm gonna get
this there's no this isn't you know this
this is so beyond this isn't going to
happen and and obviously because I was
so pissed off when I turned up they were
like wow she's got real attitude this is
great and it worked but but yeah I mean
yeah it was mind-boggling just the size
of it I mean at the amount of people I
mean it's still mind-boggling you know
the amount of people that it takes to
make those sort of films and the amount
of money that you can literally see in
front of you is quite frightening what
about the experience as an actress in
the mists of such economic well I mean I
think it was more I think really what I
can say not really remembering it very
well is that the Johnny Depp playing
that part because on on the page it was
an absolutely straight lead there was
none of the kind of Jack Sparrow knows
none of the drunkenness none of none of
that was within the Richards none of the
Keith Richards was in there and
so the first time I saw it was at the
read-through and just going wow you can
make that from that that how does that
imagination you know is is astonishing
and at that point having a surprise for
the director as well the demos I think I
read our debt the director knew I'm not
well actually knows I mean he said that
the producers didn't and I think they
might have been quite shocked and and
him saying look this is the only way
that I can play this and so if you don't
want it then that's fine but this is the
way I'm going to play it so seeing that
kind of you know that that that
imagination and that that kind of the
balls of it was quite astonishing from
that you went to another brookheimer
extravaganza with King Arthur and that
kind of brings us to the fact that you
have had to do master so many physical
sports archery yeah you name it I'm just
wondering what happens as an actress had
his one prepare for being so multi
athletic I was a very athletic teenager
I really enjoyed sports so it all see I
mean and I was 18 when I did King Arthur
and it just seemed like a very natural
thing to do I really enjoyed all of that
I really enjoyed being with the stunt
guys I loved learning how to knife fight
and and sword fight and I loved it all
and I was really you know as a point
where I was quite an angry teenager and
you know you don't get the angry young
women roles you get a lot of the angry
young men roles but not necessarily the
other way around and so I think I felt
up to the challenge and this kind of
fueled your performance in that one I
think it was more the blue paint that
filled my performance if anything did
and beer 2006 was your first
collaboration with you're probably most
prolific collaborator which was director
Joe Wright with Pride and Prejudice can
you talk about your first experiences
meeting Joe and what he's like as a
director the meeting didn't go well we
hated each other he came he flew over to
Montreal where I was shooting a film
called the jacket and I had to be up at
5:00 in the morning the next morning
again Pride and Prejudice was something
that I didn't want to go for because it
was my favorite book
and I couldn't bear the rejection if he
turn me down so I'd actually said to my
agents please don't put me up for this
and they'd said note we're putting you
up for it and because pirates had come
out the producers were obviously very
keen Joe Wright wasn't very keen so he'd
been full that clear oh no he's not a
man that minces his words he makes
things very clear yeah so he came into
the interview not wanting you and you
came into the interview not warning yes
and he was two hours late
because he'd flown in from New York and
something had happened so it was
suddenly ten o'clock in the evening and
I had to get up at 4:30 in the morning
and I was shooting the next day and he
was really angry and I was kind of like
oh this guy really hates me and what am
I doing here anyway it was an awful
meeting and for some reason everybody
persuaded us to meet again in London
sort of two weeks later and we met in a
in a in a hotel bar and suddenly just
clicked and and instantly I started
telling him to [ __ ] off and he started
telling me to [ __ ] off and that's been
our relationship ever since a beautiful
chemistry it's a wonderful chemistry
yeah can you talk about your experiences
making Pride and Prejudice because it
was a a project that a lot of people had
trepidation about there'd been the
classic miniseries before and it was as
you said yourself a much beloved classic
yeah it was terrifying and I think you
know particularly with books like that
but particularly Pride and Prejudice you
know people who love it see themselves
as Elizabeth Bennett you know so you are
never going to be the image that they
have of Elizabeth Bennett because it
will be them so it was it was kind of
terror it was terrifying going into it
and how much were you able to bring your
version of Elizabeth Bennett well it was
something that I'd been absolutely
obsessed by since I was I think about
seven or eight and in fact I had a
doll's house at home that was Pemberley
and I had all the characters in and it
has a miniature version my mum still has
at home it has a miniature version of
Pride and Prejudice in it so it really
was it had been a complete nutter
obsession i'm dyslexic so I hadn't
actually read the novel but I had it on
book tape and again just used to listen
to the book tape over and over and over
and over
/ so I had a very clear sense of who she
was because she was me you know as she
is everybody else you know she was me so
I did know that I wanted how I knew what
I wanted to do but it was still a
terrifying thing and your collaboration
with Joe did it permit that kind of
creative passion to come through for
Elizabeth yeah I mean I think I think
with Joe you know he at that particular
point being a teenager who's come out of
sort of big blockbuster films there was
a lot of criticism and a lot of people
saying she [ __ ] she can't act you can't
do it what's the point
she's pouty she's thin and of course
being being a teenager you do read it
all and you do listen to it all and you
go oh my god I'm that awful I'm really
am that awful and you know Joe was the
first person actually with John Mabry
that I mentioned it a film just before
called the jacket and I've worked with
John Maybury twice and and I had both
both of them back-to-back
who went put your head down work you can
do this prove them wrong and you know
anybody needs that kind of support and I
was incredibly lucky to have got it at
19 you know at that particular time
where they just went you can do it and
that belief really really was sort of
has meant so much and continues to you
know I've made three films with Joe two
films with John and they've both been
amazing after you made another Pirates
movie and you want to talk a little bit
tyrunt's part two for you or ha pirates
so many pirates it took such a long time
I think I started it when I was 17 and I
didn't finish it until I was 21 so it
was sort of College it was College it
was piratical College yeah I mean I just
weird I don't really remember a lot of
it it was a lot of green screen a lot of
being hot a lot of running around I mean
the the second two films weren't written
necessarily when we started so it was a
lot of but the the sets had been made so
remember a particular time sort of going
onto set and having no idea why we were
there or it was Chinese and I thought
wow we in China and nobody could really
tell because they didn't quite know and
nobody had given so because you have to
get lots of every executive has to say
yes to the script and they
hadn't but we needed to shoot the scene
so I remember being given a speech that
was written on sort of the back of the
piece of no paper and said but what does
it mean and this don't worry just just
say it just say it so standing there
okay I'll say this I've got no idea yeah
it's kind of yes they're they're amazing
creations um those things and Johnny
Depp was just saying be Jack Sparrow be
Jack's I mean you know once you've got a
character like that you can you can be
that character yeah Wow
after you made the second Pirates movie
you collaborated again with Joe right
for the very big canvas work of
atonement uh talk to us about that
experience because here is Joe leaving
the 18th century and moving up yeah I
mean I think the thing that Joe always
does which is incredible is create a
family and he did it on Pride and
Prejudice and we'd all live in the same
place and there'd be parties every
weekend and you socialize and you you
know it's very much it's sort of what
what the theater community is like you
know and that's what and he also makes
sure that there's rehearsal at least two
or three weeks which is pretty much
unheard of in film you know at the
beginning and he did exactly the same
thing on Atonement so so you know I was
living in a house with with Benedict
Cumberbatch and with all the other
actors and and you know and it was very
much we're in this together we're living
together you live it and you breathe it
and and it's an extraordinary thing
because at the time it feels like the
most important thing on earth it feels
like you know it has to be everything
and I think really making films is a
very strange thing to do but it does
have to be that important you know it
has to feel that important at the time
and that's what I always loved about
working with Joe is he makes it feel
like life and death of course it isn't
you know you come away at the end of it
and you go like what it was a movie but
but at the time you know it really it
really is that important we'll talk
about that that creative ferment does
that come primarily from having a long
rehearsal period or what produces that
kind of intensity I wish I could answer
that I mean I think yes I think I think
it is I think it is the rehearsal room
because in it the whole point of a
rehearsal room is making mistakes you
know it's creating a safe space and a
safe environment so that you have the
time to fail which isn't what a film set
is
film set is you know we have to shoot
this scene now we have to get it done by
the end of the day I don't know is not
something that you can say on a film set
but I don't know is a really important
thing to be able to say when you're kind
of developing a character and it's also
you know once you've fallen down in
front of your fellow actors once you've
made a mistake once you've done
something terribly they it kind of binds
you together as a team and once you've
found the way that it works it binds you
together as a team it doesn't
necessarily when you're on set because
then you're just going oh my god this
doesn't work and what the hell are we
going to do in that panic sets in but I
think that yeah that time of bonding is
is really important for her CIL's are
kind of a luxury I mean I'm sure you've
done many most of your films haven't
permitted that kind of process what
happens then you really hope it's going
to be okay and sometimes it's not and
some and you know I mean I think as you
go on you know you learn how to you
learn how to fake it you learn how to to
create characters on your own you know
you do the preparation that you need on
your own whether that's working with an
acting coach whether that's working with
a dialogue coach whether that's just
going through you know you you learn
your your trade and I think that's what
most most people do a lot of us have
never been on a film set can you talk
about the feeling you all have about
whether a film is going well or not
going you have no idea I mean you you
have no idea about the end result really
I don't think I've been very wrong about
a couple of them both ways unfortunately
I mean I think you know you can you can
only hope to do the best work that you
can that day because film is a
collaborative medium there is a million
times where it can go wrong and there
are a million times when it can go right
as well but you know you can not have
communicated properly to a director and
the director can not have communicated
properly to the crew and the crew yeah I
mean it can it there are a million it is
a miracle when it actually works it's
never what I imagined it's going to be
can you speak about your biggest
surprise in finally seeing a film Vegas
their own a surprise really
I mean they really are when they work
they're all a surprise when they don't
you go oh okay but ya know they are I
mean I think begin again was a surprise
that it worked because it was 25 days
and we were really up against it and it
was a lot of improvisation and it was
and I'd never really done that before
and and it was such a flash that it was
sort of like I've got no idea what just
happened there
so that was great when that worked but
equally imitation game you know because
it was a difficult subject it's a
difficult subject matter you haven't
seen it so you won't know but I'm you
know it's it's it's a really tricky one
and it's a tricky one to kind of to make
that subject thrilling if you're not
necessarily of a mathematical mind you
know I mean it's oh yeah they're all
they're all a surprise we were in 2008
you made a classic film at least in my
mind the Duchess I which cast you back
into the 18th century and that brings up
the whole topic I can't think of an
actress that has done more historical
periods than you Helena Bonham Carter
but I mean most English actresses
actually have done a lot of period but
yeah go on what is it like to live the
past and I love it you know I mean I've
always loved history and I love the sort
of sense of freedom because you can
imagine what it's like nobody knows you
know you're not you're not constrained
by what we know of today we know what
our society is we know what our cities
look like we know how we dress we know
how we work you know when you kind of
you're dealing with 1860 okay you can
pick up a history book but really if I
tell you it was slightly different and I
say well I've read a different history
book you're not going to completely know
that I'm lying you know I mean so
there's a lot of freedom in it which I
really enjoy and I love the imagination
of it you know and I love the fact that
we think we've changed so much and human
nature hasn't changed you know we make
some same mistakes again and again and
again and again and I'm sort of
fascinated by that in the case of the
Duchess you had Amanda Foreman's
fabulous book about the Duchess did that
guide you in terms of your own
historical researcher yeah yeah you know
um yeah it was hugely based on that it
was bad
I can't quite remember but it was better
the problem is I never remember any of
the research I've done if I could
remember I'd be really clever but it
just kind of completely leaves my brain
as soon as I read the books yes I did I
mean it that was an amazing resource and
actually I think a lot of the reason
that I love doing films based in a
different time period is doing the
research you know what is the research
process like for you I mean in the case
of the Duchess you've got Amanda's book
it's as much reading as possible in the
time that I've got yeah so I mean and
that's and there's always more that you
can do and there's always afterwards if
you revisit a period like the 1940s
which I've done sort of three times you
know you always think I wish I'd known
that back then because that would have
changed something what I did with that
character you know um but yeah you just
do as much as you can is there a
historical period that you feel most
comfortable in in the past oh no I think
of a decade you haven't done the decade
I haven't oh yeah I'm over I'd like a
bit of the French Revolution that would
be quite fun okay great um the first
time you sang was in begin again right
or no I'd actually sung in a be edge of
the edge of luck which your mother wrote
the screen which my mother did write the
screenplay for yes and there you were in
1940's London yes and Wales yes yes and
I did sing um she made me it wasn't
written in there and then all of a
sudden it was you know it's that mother
thing where she thinks I've got good
voice she said wouldn't it be nice if
you sang and you want to go [ __ ] off no
it wouldn't be nice like that and all of
a sudden you can't do that she's the
writer and the director agrees and
suddenly I'm up there singing terrifying
and I vowed at that point never to do it
again and then you did yeah and then
enough time passed and I forgot suddenly
I've read like begin again I go oh yeah
that's a really good idea a year later
your West End debut with more years the
misanthrope do you want to talk about
the shift from screen to stage um yes um
I think the stage is always if that's
always what I'd plan to do you know
that's what my parents did that's sort
of what I grew up in that's I mean I saw
way more theatre when I was little than
I did film and film was a total accident
I wasn't allowed to do film when I
television sorry wait a minute theatre
I'll get there in the end theater when I
was little because it would have meant
too much time off school or it would
have meant kind of late nights and not
being able to do the day so I've never
allowed to do it and then suddenly film
took over and and I'd got to a point
with film where I knew that I'd hit a
brick wall and I sort of really kind of
physically felt not being able to
emotionally sort of get to that other
bit that I knew was there and I was
seeing characters in a different way but
I couldn't quite reach it was it because
of the limitation of parts that were
offered or I'd I think no I mean I think
it was I mean maybe it could have been
that but no I think it was technical I
think I technically didn't know how to
how to get over whatever that wall was I
couldn't I think now knowing actually I
really badly suffered from stage fright
and not having been on a stage I
couldn't I didn't know that it was stage
fright so I suddenly yeah I got to this
wall and my dad said well you know you
haven't actually done what you meant to
do and what you wanted to do for your
entire life you haven't actually been on
stage so you should do that and then I
thought I was 24 and I thought actually
if I don't do it now
the fear of it will build to such an
extent that I'm never going to do it so
I've got it's got to be now it sort of
felt like it was going to be never and
it was a fine yeah so stage fright fully
manifest well yeah it fully manifested
itself which just meant that I went oh
okay so that's actually what it was on
set and so that's what I've got to work
on because actually what it needs to be
is it's relaxation you know which is
what every actor you have to work from a
place of relaxation in order to sort of
feel free to kind of try things and yeah
actually being on stage and actually it
was the first time that I really saw
other actors prepare because as much as
there was rehearsal with Jo it was still
a very kind of film like rehearsal where
really everybody's prepared before and
everybody knows what they're doing
whereas with this one it was really
seeing actors go from nothing to
preparing a role and it was fascinating
after the experience that you almost
have a moment of crisis saying maybe I
should do staged exclusively know I'd
had the moment of crisis before no
no no it was I mean no I just it was I'm
again uh with that one the preparation
of it I prepared it with such a lot of
fear that I knew that fear was a part of
the performance and so I wanted to do
theater very quickly again because the
fear had gone and I thought right okay
now this is interesting because now the
fear is gone now you can get to
somewhere different which happened when
I did the Children's Hour which was only
sort of a year later 2010 was I think a
really fascinating year in your career
you did never let me go and my favorite
film of yours A Dangerous Method where
you played Carl Jung's patient and then
mistress uh sabina spielrein can you
talk about what it was like to work with
David Cronenberg amazing yeah he's
incredible I mean he's you do two takes
most you do two shots most you know I
mean he he knows exactly what he wants
everybody is so unbelievably prepared
and totally ready and completely
concentrated because you go in knowing
that he'll he only he expects you to get
it in one you know he expects you to be
ready he expects it to come out and so
it's amazing the kind of shift in
concentration you know quite often on
film sets if you know you've got 13
takes if you've know you've got three
days to do something and can get a
little bit flabby you know people can
kind of go oh well I'll find out I'll
get there which sometimes can be great
but people find it at different times so
as actors quite often you won't feel
that magic thing where it's real whereas
when you work with David because you
know it's got to come out the magic real
strange thing that is kind of like the
drug of acting happens very quickly
this brings us to the whole topic of
directors we talked about Joe and now
David can you talk about the whole
chemistry that goes on on the film set
between a director and an actor I don't
know what it is you know I mean I think
I've worked with with people who are
really different and I think that I can
go oh yes that's the kind of director
that I like and then I'll work with
somebody completely different because
Joe and David are totally different and
you go oh no but this is a whole you
know this is a whole other
and this works for some reason and I
think it's just somebody who gives you
confidence or gives you you feel like
you're supported anake you want to talk
about that your third collaboration with
Joe right yes um quite a remarkable
because when Tom Stoppard wrote the
script originally he conceived of it as
a grand Russian epic and then something
changed we didn't have the money yeah so
no they realized that to do it in the
naturalistic way would have cost 60
million and they only gave him I think
while only but just under 30 and there
was just no way of doing it so he had to
very quickly think on his toes and kind
of go okay this has got to change and so
in about a week or something ridiculous
he came up with this concept of it being
set pretty much in one location which
was this sort of magical theater um so
if only what was the like when he had to
approach Stoppard and basically tell him
this isn't going to be set in Russia I
don't know I wasn't part of that
conversation you know I mean I I think
everybody was up for it you know we all
wanted to get the film made we all
understood that there was no way to make
it that nobody was going to give 60
million for that and so everybody was
like okay let's go for the challenge I
mean also in Joe's work and being a
friend of his and having creative
conversations I always knew that he was
getting more and more and more
interested in in going away from
naturalism and doing something kind of
very different so I wasn't surprised at
all when he said okay come to my office
I want to show you something and I was
like oh [ __ ] hell
and it just had all of these pictures of
this thing this theater and I was like
right and he's like and there's going to
be dancing and we're going to do like
really weird movement and like all right
okay
good did it call for a different
approach to your performance given the
fact that it was quasi naturalistic um
if yes and no I mean that the dancing
aspect was a big thing and
and physically really really tough and
actually the whole way that he shot it
because we were you know we we wanted to
keep a certain naturalism to her and
heightened but but you know and and we
wanted it to be very emotional and quite
often you know if you get a very
stylized piece the performances are
quite neutral because it's really
difficult you know you're doing 30 takes
and you've got to get that tier two time
out to drop exactly when the camera
spins in and gets you through that
mirror and it is going to take 30 takes
to get that because the focus is going
to take 25 takes to get it you know so
it was technically the most difficult
thing I've ever done
definitely even though it was on a
smaller budget than the grand scale it
was originally envisioned yeah I mean I
think it would have been much easier as
an actor to film it if it had all been
naturalistic but it would have been less
challenging and therefore less fun uh
brings us to your latest project the
imitation game how did this come about
and what led you to the discovery of
Joan Clarke um it came about and they
phoned up and offered it to me that's
how it came about but I mean I'd first
read about Alan Turing in about 2009 in
The Guardian where they'd been this big
push to kind of get him pardoned and
read an article and gone how do I not
know about this person and what he did
and what had been done to him which is
so completely horrific and I had a
weirdly that day lunch with my agent and
said you know how about this guy and
she'd she'd actually seen a play about
him sort of a few years before and then
two or three years after that phoned up
and said do you remember that Alan
Turing conversation well they've they've
offered you a part in it you want to do
it and I said yes before I'd even read
the script or really knew what the part
was just because I think as everybody in
that project felt they wanted to be a
part of trying to get his name to a
wider public well not only is Turing
brought to the public attention but so
too is the crucial role of Joan Clark
and as one of the only women in the film
I wanted to talk about okay yeah
if you could talk about her pioneering
role in all this yeah I mean um do the
Joan that you see in the film it is it
is a drama and it is no documentary so
she's a little bit
an amalgamation of a couple of people
but it is true that she was part of the
team that broke the enigma code in the
Second World War and she was very
briefly engaged to Alan Turing before he
said I can't do this I'm gay and she
actually did I mean which happened the
next day well no in reality they were
actually they were engaged for six
months so and and and actually as you
will if you see the film as happens in
the film you know he says I'm gay and
she says oh no it doesn't matter and and
actually that did happen she did have a
minute of going No maybe it'll be all
right
and then going home now maybe it worked
you've made movies all over the world I
wonder if you could talk specifically
what it's like as a Briton to make films
in Britain um you know I mean over the
course of my career I've really gone out
of my way to make films in Britain I've
wanted to it's very much my home and I'm
fascinated with my culture I suppose
very simply there's less money
the food's not as good we get we have
shorter working days because we can't
afford the overtime which is quite nice
but yeah I mean you know I I love
working there I love the fact that it's
a very small industry and I know a lot
of the crew members you know so you
instantly step into it and you feel like
you're in a family already and that's
fantastic looking back on your career uh
what do you see is your favorite parts
of it oh god I don't know I feel like
I've died looking back um um I mean I
think um I think Dangerous Method is the
thing that I'm most proud of because it
was the decision to play it like that
was one that I always knew would split
people and it did and it felt quite Punk
and it was uh yeah we would hear it in
torment
almost I was very definitely in torment
yeah I mean but it was also you know as
far as a research time it was the
happiest that I've had I just found it
totally fascinating and working with a
director that when no don't go for the
easy option go for the one that's going
to split everybody why wouldn't you what
was amazing
and when you took the world originally
did you know that Cronenberg was going
to turn you into such a difficult no I
mean all he said to me was I've hired
you you do it okay anything else and he
was just like um yeah just make sure the
ticks on the face go away do the work
and show me what you come up with so I
actually prepared it two ways and I did
the kind of what I and what still would
have been a much more palatable way and
maybe that would have been the right way
but it wouldn't have been the fun way
and then I did this other one and he
won't know I want that one that's so
weird
okay luckily for us New Yorkers you're
coming back next fall to do a stage
version of Terror at camp will you talk
a little about that yes it's a comedy no
it's not it's sort of the darkest piece
of play that I think I've ever read and
it's weirdly the thing that has been
offered to me it's it's come around to
me this is the third time now that I've
been offered it not in this production
but various times and I don't know if
anybody knows what Theresa can is about
but there's madness and a lot of killing
and death and suicide it can't get much
darker so you know one of those things
we're like why do you keep thinking of
me when you trying to say about me and
but yeah for some reason this time it
came around and I turned it down before
because I didn't get it and because I
was terrified of it and I'm still
terrified of it and I met the director
today and I'm even more terrified he's
wonderful but it is terrifying but it's
fascinating and weird and dark and will
be interesting in just talking with you
over the last few minutes I've heard the
word terror mentioned repeatedly yes ah
that seems to be a motivating factor for
you in how you choose your roles I know
that sounds [ __ ] up doesn't it oh yeah
it is
I think it's that it's the kind of
constant challenge it makes you feel
alive doesn't it when you get through
something like that you go look I'm
still here I'm still right you know dust
yourself off and carry on any other
terrifying prospects in the future in
terms of film roles no but I'm looking
for them I haven't I have I've found it
the problem with having done so many in
a way and I've been very fortunate so
it's not really a problem with having
done so many as you
nigo no I've done that don't do that
again now I've done that so I keep
looking for the thing that's going to be
the most terrifying and the most
challenging and I haven't found one yet
we will be looking with you we thank you
so much for joining us tonight you very
much I'm wondering if when you're
preparing for a role if you're thinking
does this one go for the jugular or
should I let this one wash over me as
you're approaching it which approach do
you like if I let anything wash over me
my life would be much easier um
I don't I can't explain it I tend to I
tend to go for the jugular every time